Me, I'm not crazy about the beach. It's hard to think of a less comfortable place to read a book than flat on a blanket under the scorching sun. Going in the waves-- totally fine for a little bit, but, like, all day? And like many people over 40, I have no desire to ever be seen in a bathing suit by anyone ever for the rest of my life.
我呢，其实不太喜欢海滩。很难想象有什么比平躺在烈日下的毯子上看书更不舒服的地方了。去海浪里泡一泡——玩一会儿还可以，但要待上一整天？而且像许多40多岁的人一样，我这辈子都不想再让任何人看到我穿泳衣的样子了。
But know how many times I've been to the beach this summer? OK, there were two quickie day trips and a seven-day beach vacation. I don't like the beach, but, I've been. A bunch.
但你知道我今年夏天去过多少次海滩吗？好吧，有两次匆忙的一日游和一次七天的海滩度假。我不喜欢海滩，但我还是去了。好几次呢。
And why? Well, because people I love love the beach. Hating the beach during summer-- and I believe I can say this with authority from personal experience. Hating the beach in summer is like being a Jew at Christmas. You can try to sit it out, but it's just too big. At some point, you're going to drink some eggnog.
为什么呢？嗯，因为我爱的人喜欢海滩。夏天讨厌海滩——我相信凭我的个人经验可以很有权威地说——夏天讨厌海滩就像圣诞节里的犹太人。你可以试着置身事外，但它实在太盛行了。在某个时刻，你总归会喝点蛋酒的。
And you know what? When I go to the beach, I try-- I really try-- to get into it, to have a nice time, to appreciate the waves, and the sand, and the heat. And I think about the many hundreds and thousands of years that families have brought their kids to the water's edge to play pretty much exactly the same dumb way that we play in the sand and waves today. How many ways are there to do that anyway? And you know, some people really love it so much.
而且你知道吗？当我来到海滩时，我试过——我真的试过——去融入它，享受一段美好时光，去欣赏波浪、沙滩和热度。我想到成百上千年来，无数家庭带孩子来到水边，玩着和我们今天在沙滩和海浪中玩的一模一样愚蠢的游戏。反正还能怎么玩呢？而且你知道，有些人确实非常喜欢这样。
A while back, here on our radio show, we also had this article about somebody like that. At the time, he was a 66-year-old lifeguard who was suing New York state for age discrimination. And I just want to pause on that for a second-- a 66-year-old lifeguard.
不久前，在我们电台节目里，我们也有一篇关于这样的人的文章。当时，他是一名66岁的救生员，正在起诉纽约州年龄歧视。我想在这里暂停一下——一位66岁的救生员。
All of us here on our staff, we had no idea that could even exist. We all thought lifeguarding is something you do when you're in high school, maybe a couple years after, into your 20s. Like, who's still lifeguarding at 66?
我们全台的工作人员都不知道居然还有这种事。我们都以为救生员是高中生做的事，或者毕业后做个几年，到20多岁为止。谁会在66岁还当救生员呢？
And then it was even more of a question when we realized that the lifeguard in the story, he has another job. He's a lawyer. He's a working lawyer. His name is Roy Lester. He's a bankruptcy attorney. He's got his own firm on Long Island. And then he lifeguards every weekend in the summer. And can I just say, today on our program we have stories about people like him-- people who love the beach, not people like me.
当我们意识到故事里的这位救生员还有另一份工作时，就更令人惊讶了。他是一位律师。他是一名在职律师。他叫罗伊·莱斯特（Roy Lester）。他是一位破产律师。他在长岛有自己的律师事务所。而且他每个夏天周末都会去当救生员。我可以这么说，今天我们的节目里有关于像他这样的人的故事——那些热爱海滩的人，而不是像我这样的人。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We prepared today a program to listen to with the sun beating down on you, the humidity through the roof, a show of people embracing the beach, people who are sons of the beach. And let's just get right to it with Act One.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们今天制作了一档节目，适合你在烈日当空、湿度爆表的时候收听，这是一档关于那些拥抱海滩的人的节目，他们是“海滩之子”。让我们直接进入第一幕。
Act One, the Grapes of Wrath. So one of our producers, Dana Chivvis, she went out to Long Island and met that guy, Roy Lester, the 66-year-old attorney lifeguard who was suing New York state. Basically the deal is that they tried to make him wear a Speedo. He refused. He lost his job. Here's Dana.
第一幕，《愤怒的葡萄》。我们的一位制作人达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）去长岛见了那个叫罗伊·莱斯特的人，就是那位起诉纽约州的66岁律师兼救生员。基本上情况是，他们试图强迫他穿三角泳裤（Speedo）。他拒绝了。他丢了工作。下面是达娜的采访。
If you asked Roy, why are you still lifeguarding at 66, he barely understands the question. It's so self-evident to him. It's been his life since he was 16. He and his buddies were kings of the beach. He lived with other lifeguards. His best man at his wedding was a lifeguard.
如果你问罗伊，为什么66岁了还要当救生员，他几乎听不懂这个问题。对他来说这太理所当然了。从16岁起，这就是他的生活。他和伙伴们是海滩之王。他和其他救生员住在一起。他婚礼上的伴郎也是救生员。
Their kids grew up playing together on the beach while they were on duty. He never wanted to leave this job. Even when he went to law school in California, he came back to lifeguard every summer.
他们的孩子在他们当班时一起在海滩上长大。他从来没想过放弃这份工作。即使在加州上法学院时，他每年夏天都会回来当救生员。
In law school, aren't you supposed to have an internship in a law firm or something like that?
在法学院，不是应该在律师事务所之类的机构实习吗？
You're supposed to.
本该如此。
Did you not do that?
你没那么做吗？
No, I did not do that. I never took it quite that seriously. The idea of giving up the summer was something I just couldn't do.
没有，我没做。我从来没有把它看得那么重。放弃夏天（去实习）这种事我实在做不到。
He's not alone. At Jones Beach, where he worked for 40 years, there are dozens of guys-- teachers, firemen, police-- who stayed with it into their 60s. Lifeguarding at Jones Beach is such a thing that a former lifeguard made a film about it. It's called Jones Beach Boys. Roy insisted I watch it. I did. It was awesome. Here's my favorite song from it.
他不孤单。在琼斯海滩（Jones Beach），他工作了40年的地方，有几十个这样的家伙——老师、消防员、警察——他们一直坚持到60多岁。琼斯海滩的救生事业非常出名，甚至有一位前救生员为此拍了一部电影。名字叫《琼斯海滩男孩》（Jones Beach Boys）。罗伊坚持让我看。我看了。太棒了。这是我里面最喜欢的一首歌。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
(SINGING) We're going for the rescue and getting to the victim.
（歌唱）我们去救援，接近受害者。
"We're going for the rescue and getting to the victim." I never really appreciated how thrilling lifeguarding is until Roy talked about rescues. We were sitting in his law office.
“我们去救援，接近受害者。”我从未真正体会到救生是多么令人兴奋，直到罗伊谈起救援。我们当时坐在他的律师事务所里。
The exhilaration of a good rescue is unlike anything you've ever had. And you don't get that. I sit here, and I shuffle papers. I wouldn't call it exciting. I wouldn't call it rewarding.
那种成功救援后的兴奋感是前所未有的。而你没法体会。我坐在这里，处理文件。我不会说这很令人兴奋。也不会说这有什么成就感。
But this is-- you're actually accomplishing something. You're up there, and all of a sudden you're going out in the water, and the rest of world is behind you. There's nothing else except between you getting from your stand to that victim. That's the only thing, and it's great. It's a great feeling.
但这个是——你真的有所作为。你在那儿，突然间你就冲进水里，整个世界都在你身后。除了你从观察台冲向受害者这一段路程，别无他物。就是那种感觉，太棒了。那是一种很棒的感觉。
How many people do you think you've rescued in your career?
你觉得你职业生涯救了多少人？
Over 1,000.
超过1000个。
1,000?
1000个？
Yeah. You have to remember, there were times we would have 40 rescues in an hour.
是的。你要记住，有时候我们一小时内就要进行40次救援。
What? Why? What? Why?
什么？为什么？什么？为什么？
Because you have people that come down to Jones Beach who really don't know about swimming. So-- especially when you have a current. And you can get a very strong current at Jones Beach.
因为来琼斯海滩的人很多真的不会游泳。所以——特别是有离岸流的时候。琼斯海滩的洋流非常强。
1,000 rescues, that's way more rescues than David Hasselhoff did on Baywatch. I figure two rescues per episode, 10 years on the air, Roy would still beat him by 560 rescues. Which is to say, Roy is one of the lifeguardiest lifeguards there is. He had two wins at the national lifeguard competition. He served as an expert lifeguard witness in court cases.
1000次救援，这比《海滩救护队》（Baywatch）里大卫·哈塞尔霍夫（David Hasselhoff）救的人多多了。我算了一下，每集两次救援，播出10年，罗伊也比他多出560次救援。也就是说，罗伊是最名副其实的救生员之一。他在全国救生员比赛中赢过两次。他还在法庭案件中担任救生领域的专家证人。
And all was well in his happy lifeguarding world until the Speedo mishegoss began in 2007. Here's what happened. If you're a lifeguard at Jones Beach, you have to take a physical fitness test every year to prove that you're still able to do the job. It includes a speed test in a pool. You have to swim 100 yards in a minute 20, which is actually pretty fast. A lot of these guys train all year for it.
在他幸福的救生员世界里，一切都很好，直到2007年三角泳裤（Speedo）的闹剧开始。情况是这样的。如果你是琼斯海滩的救生员，每年都要参加体能测试以证明你还能胜任这份工作。其中包括在泳池进行的游泳速度测试。你必须在一分二十秒内游完100码，这其实相当快。这些人很多为此训练了一整年。
For 15 years, Roy took the swim test in his preferred swimsuit, a pair of jammers. They look like bike shorts without the butt cushion. If you're watching the Olympics right now, all the male swimmers are wearing them. They're tight, and they go down to just above the knee.
15年来，罗伊一直穿着他偏爱的泳裤参加测试，那是平角泳裤（jammers）。它们看起来像没有护垫的自行车短裤。如果你正在看奥运会，所有的男游泳运动员都穿这种。它们很紧，长度刚好到膝盖上方。
But when Roy showed up for the test in 2007, he was told no jammers. His bosses at the office of parks and recreation said, you can only do the test in one of the official Jones Beach lifeguard swimsuits, which means you have three choices-- board shorts, trunks, or Speedo.
但在2007年罗伊去参加测试时，他被告知不能穿平角泳裤。公园与娱乐办公室的老板说，测试只能穿琼斯海滩官方规定的泳装，这意味着你只有三个选择——沙滩裤、运动短裤或三角泳裤。
Board shorts and trunks are loose, so nobody really takes a swim test in them because they create more drag and slow you down. So in effect, state officials were saying to Roy, you have to take the test in a Speedo. Roy said, no way. I won't do it. And he hasn't been a lifeguard at Jones Beach since.
沙滩裤和运动短裤很宽松，所以没人真的穿着它们进行游泳测试，因为阻力大，会拖慢速度。所以实际上，州政府官员是在告诉罗伊，你必须穿三角泳裤参加测试。罗伊说，没门。我不干。从那以后他就再也没在琼斯海滩当过救生员了。
It was one of those feelings like, am I making the right decision? I'm throwing away a 40-year career over a principle. It was a difficult decision, a very difficult decision.
那感觉就像，我做的是正确的决定吗？我为了一个原则放弃了40年的职业生涯。这是一个艰难的决定，非常艰难。
How long did it take you to decide?
你花了多久做决定？
A second.
一秒钟。
I really need to point out he would only have to wear the Speedo for the test, which lasts a minute and 20 seconds. On the job, he'd wear board shorts. Most of the lifeguards do, young and old.
我真的得指出，他只需要在测试时穿那件三角泳裤，过程仅一分二十秒。工作时，他可以穿沙滩裤。大多数救生员，无论老少，都会穿沙滩裤。
Why not just put it on for the test, though?
为什么测试时不干脆穿上呢？
Why didn't Rosa Parks just go to the back of the bus? There were plenty of seats.
罗莎·帕克斯（Rosa Parks）当初为什么不干脆去坐公交车后排？那时候座位多得是呢。
Of course, what Roy was fighting for is quite different from what Rosa Parks was fighting for. But to Roy it's the principle of the thing, standing up to age discrimination. When I read about all this in The New York Times, I really didn't understand. What's the connection between a Speedo and age discrimination? I've certainly seen older dudes in Speedos.
当然，罗伊争取的东西和罗莎·帕克斯争取的东西完全不同。但对罗伊来说，这是原则问题，是为了抵制年龄歧视。当我第一次在《纽约时报》读到这些时，我真没看懂。三角泳裤和年龄歧视之间有什么联系？我当然见过年纪大的人穿三角泳裤。
So I went out and met Roy on a beach not far from his house in Long Island. It was 6:45 in the morning. He was about to go for a mile swim before work.
所以我去长岛他家附近的海滩见了罗伊。当时是早上6点45分。他正准备在上班前游一英里。
So Roy, can you describe what you're wearing right now?
那么罗伊，你能描述一下你现在穿的是什么吗？
Well, it's a wetsuit. It's a short-sleeve wetsuit. And I have my jammers on underneath.
好吧，是潜水服。短袖潜水服。里面穿着我的平角泳裤。
Roy brought one of his official Jones Beach Speedos to the beach to show me.
罗伊带了一件他的琼斯海滩官方三角泳裤到海滩给我看。
Just describe it for me.
给我描述一下。
It's an exaggerated thong, for lack of a better word.
用个不太恰当的词，它就是一条加长版的丁字裤。
But it's full coverage in the back. So it's not quite a thong, right?
但它后部是有遮盖的。所以不完全是丁字裤，对吧？
No, not quite a thong, right.
不，不太完全是丁字裤。
But to Roy and lots of guys, it might as well be a thong, which is why the Speedo has earned a stable of nicknames-- the weenie bikini, the dingaling sling, the Speed-don't, the banana hammock, the grape smuggler, the Miami meat tent, the Saint-Tropez truffle duffle, the scrote tote.
但对罗伊和很多男人来说，它和丁字裤没两样，这就是为什么三角泳裤被起了一堆绰号——比如“小鸡泳裤”、“晃动吊带”、“Speed-don't”（Speedo的谐音反转）、“香蕉吊床”、“葡萄偷运者”、“迈阿密肉块帐篷”、“圣特罗佩松露袋”、“蛋蛋袋”。
The reason the jammer is preferred by older lifeguards is that you're saying it's more discreet?
平角泳裤受年长救生员青睐的原因是，你觉得它更谨慎？
Modest.
更端庄。
More modest--
更端庄——
Yes.
是的。
--than the Speedo.
——比三角泳裤。
Yes.
是的。
Because it covers your thighs.
因为它遮住了你的大腿。
I don't want to get graphic, but you're-- the word begins with B. Basically you're hanging out with the Speedo.
我不想说得太露骨，但你穿三角泳裤的时候，简直就是——（话语停顿）。
I get it now, I think.
我明白了，我想我懂了。
And you don't really-- with the jammers, it's not like that.
穿平角泳裤就不会那样。
There's like a little bit more of a roof over your house.
就好像房子上多盖了一层顶。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
I see.
我明白了。
This is the nut of his argument. Roy says once he passed 50, he felt self-conscious in a Speedo. And nobody should have to feel self-conscious to get a job.
这就是他论点的核心。罗伊说，过了50岁后，他穿三角泳裤会感到难为情。没有人应该为了保住工作而感到难为情。
So Roy refuses to put on the grape smuggler to take the swim test. A few weeks later, there's another chance to take the test. He shows up, and this time he is wearing the official Speedo. He's just got it on over his jammers.
所以罗伊拒绝穿上“葡萄偷运者”（Speedo）去参加测试。几周后，有另一次参加测试的机会。他去了，这次他穿上了官方的三角泳裤。他只是把它套在平角泳裤外面。
He showed me a video of a conversation he recorded on the pool deck that day. It was a little windy, so the sound isn't great. But he's standing in front of Sue Giuliani, who was the director of Jones Beach State Park at the time. And there he is in his jammers plus Speedo outfit, challenging her to turn him away.
他给我展示了一段那天在泳池边录下的对话视频。风有点大，所以声音不太好。但他站在当时的琼斯海滩州立公园主任苏·朱利亚尼（Sue Giuliani）面前。他身上穿着那套平角裤加三角裤的装备，挑战她让他离开。
I've made a compromise.
我做了个妥协。
That's not going to be acceptable.
那是不可接受的。
You're not going to let me swim like this?
你不让我这样游泳吗？
No.
是的。
How come?
为什么？
Because you still have jammers on. So that you cannot wear.
因为你里面还穿着平角裤。那个是不能穿的。
All right. And is there any reason why they're not allowed?
好的。有什么理由说它们不被允许吗？
We're not going to-- how many times do you want me to repeat it?
我们没必要——你要让我重复多少遍？
What?
什么？
You know why they're not allowed.
你知道为什么它们不被允许。
No, I don't. I've never been able to--
不，我不知道。我从来没能——
I've pretty much--
我已经说得很清楚了——
Joe Scalise, the director of water safety for the state beaches, cuts in.
乔·斯卡利斯（Joe Scalise），州属海滩的水上安全主管，插话了。
Are you going to comply or not?
你到底配不配合？
I am complying. I'm wearing my official suit.
我配合了。我穿着我的官方泳装。
Are you complying with what we want or not?
你配合的是我们要你穿的吗？
I'm wearing my official suit.
我穿着我的官方泳装。
So you're not swimming now?
那你是不游了？
All right, let's go.
好吧，走吧。
Did you just go home then?
那你后来就回家了？
Basically. Well, I stayed around, and I watched everybody take the test.
差不多。我在附近待了一会儿，看着大家参加测试。
Were there other people taking the test in jammers?
还有其他人穿平角裤参加测试吗？
No. No, nobody was allowed to take the test in jammers. So everybody else either put on a Speedo or put on the board shorts, something like that.
没有。没人被允许穿平角裤测试。所以其他人要么穿了三角泳裤，要么穿了沙滩裤之类的。
Now, Roy says he could have worn board shorts or trunks and still passed the test. He says he could have worn dungarees and passed. The guy is in ridiculous shape. He does triathlons now, coaches a swim team. In 2012, he had a hip replaced, and seven weeks later he came in first in his age group in Bermuda's Round the Sound swim race, a 1.2-mile open water swim. He was still using a cane to walk.
罗伊说他本来可以穿沙滩裤或运动短裤，照样能通过测试。他说他穿工作服都能通过。这人身材好得离谱。他现在参加铁人三项，还教游泳队。2012年，他做了髋关节置换术，七周后就在百慕大“绕岛”（Round the Sound）游泳赛中获得了同年龄组第一名，那可是1.2英里的公开水域游泳。当时他走路还要用拐杖。
So the easy thing for Roy to do would be just take the test in board shorts or Speedo and keep the job he loved. Let bureaucrats be bureaucrats. Just get on with it.
所以对罗伊来说最省事的做法就是穿着沙滩裤或三角泳裤参加测试，保住他心爱的工作。让官僚们继续当官僚吧，随他们去。
That's not Roy. Roy does not back down from a fight. So he sued. He sued the New York State Office of Parks, Recreation, and Historic Preservation for $5 million.
那不是罗伊。罗伊不会在战斗面前退缩。所以他起诉了。他以500万美元起诉纽约州公园、娱乐和历史保护办公室。
Now, the easy thing for the state would have been to just let Jones Beach lifeguards wear jammers. Presumably, if they're good enough for the Olympic swim team, they're good enough for New York's lifeguards. But that's not New York state. It decided to fight.
州政府最省事的做法本来就是允许琼斯海滩的救生员穿平角裤。大概，如果这裤子够奥运代表队穿，就够纽约的救生员穿了。但这可是纽约州。它决定应战。
The lawsuit has worked its way through the lower court, which dismissed it to the appellate court, which ruled in May that it should go to trial. This has been going on for seven years-- seven years. Roy sent me a PDF of his exhibits in the case. It was 1,300 pages long.
诉讼案经过了下级法院驳回，到了上诉法院，今年5月裁定应该进入审判程序。这件事已经持续了七年——七年了。罗伊发给我一份该案证据的PDF文件。有1300页长。
And the thing I really want to know-- because I live in New York and pay taxes in New York-- is, why is the state using taxpayer dollars to fight the Speedo suit? This could all have been resolved very easily years ago if they just changed the rule, allowed the jammers. Why are Roy and the state fighting each other when they should unite against the real enemy, jellyfish?
我真的很想知道——因为我住在纽约且在纽约交税——为什么州政府要用纳税人的钱来打这场三角泳裤官司？如果他们几年前改改规定、允许穿平角裤，这事儿早就轻松解决了。为什么罗伊和州政府要互掐，而不联手对抗真正的敌人——水母呢？
Officials from the state of New York wouldn't talk to me for this story. The attorney general's office wouldn't talk. Neither would parks and rec. But they did send me the affidavit of a guy named George Gorman. He oversees all the parks in Long Island. And it lays out their side of the story.
纽约州官员不愿就这个故事接受采访。司法部长办公室也不愿谈。公园管理部门也不行。但他们寄给我一份名叫乔治·戈尔曼（George Gorman）的人的宣誓书。他监管着长岛所有的公园。宣誓书中陈述了他们的立场。
Around 2006, some of the Jones Beach lifeguards started taking the swim test in full-body swimsuits. Management became concerned that those guys were only passing because they were wearing the full-body swimsuits. So they decided to change the rules. Starting in 2007, lifeguards could only take the test in one of the three official Jones Beach uniform swimsuits-- no more full body suits and also no jammers, because jammers aren't part of the uniform.
大约在2006年，一些琼斯海滩救生员开始穿全身式泳装参加测试。管理层担心这些人是因为穿了全身泳装才通过的。于是他们决定更改规则。从2007年开始，救生员只能穿琼斯海滩制服里的三种泳装之一——不能穿全身泳装，也不能穿平角裤，因为平角裤不是制服的一部分。
In his deposition, George Gorman said, quote, "We determined it was best that the lifeguards wear the uniforms that they're assigned to wear while they're on duty." Seems reasonable, right? Not if you're Roy. He points out, if jammers really are significantly faster, wouldn't you want your lifeguards to wear a faster suit, get them out to drowning victim sooner? And as it happens, New York Parks and Rec allows lifeguards to take their qualifying test in jammers in the rest of the state.
在证词中，乔治·戈尔曼说：“我们认为，救生员在执勤时穿规定的制服最好。”看起来挺合理，对吧？如果你是罗伊，就不这么看了。他指出，如果平角裤确实明显更快，那你不是更应该让救生员穿得快一点，好更快救出溺水者吗？而且碰巧的是，纽约州公园与娱乐部在州内其他地方是允许救生员穿平角裤参加测试的。
Upstate! I went upstate to take the test, and I wore my jammers.
在上州！我去上州参加了测试，穿的就是平角裤。
You took the test upstate?
你在上州参加了测试？
Yes, and I wore my jammers. And people wore their jammers, and I have pictures of that. And that's part of the exhibit, of guys taking the test in their jammers.
是的，我穿着平角裤。其他人也都穿平角裤，我还有照片呢。这也是证据的一部分，那些家伙穿着平角裤参加测试的照片。
Upstate?
上州？
Yes, the same employer. New York State Department of Recreation, the same employer, allows the jammers.
是的，同一个雇主。纽约州娱乐部，同一个雇主，允许穿平角裤。
So your theory about this is that they're targeting Long Island because why?
所以你认为他们针对长岛的原因是什么？
Because 90% of the older, the over-50 lifeguards work on Long Island. It's the biggest group of older lifeguards anywhere.
因为90%超过50岁的救生员都在长岛工作。这是全国年长救生员最集中的地方。
For what it's worth, the state told me that the rules are different on Long Island because it's a more strenuous job lifeguarding on the ocean. Upstate, it's all lakes and pools.
顺便提一下，州政府告诉我规则在长岛不同，因为在海洋当救生员更费力。上州都是湖泊和泳池。
Why do you think it is that they don't want older lifeguards?
你觉得他们为什么不喜欢年长的救生员？
Well, I think they don't like the fact that older lifeguards have influence over the younger guys. And when you're a member of management, you don't want anybody having influence over your employees except you. And when you have to deal with a union and you have to deal with the officers of the unions who are all older guys and they know the beach, you don't want that.
我认为他们不喜欢年长的救生员对年轻人有影响力。身为管理层，你不希望任何人对你的员工有影响力，除了你自己。当你面对工会，不得不应对工会官员——那些全都是了解海滩情况的老家伙时，你是不会愿意的。
Yep, there's a lifeguard union. Roy was the president of the union for years. And at that point in 2007, when he refused to wear the Speedo, he was the union's chief negotiator. When Sue Giuliani tells him to follow the rules--
没错，这里有个救生员工会。罗伊当了好几年的工会主席。而在2007年他拒绝穿三角泳裤时，他是工会的首席谈判代表。当苏·朱利亚尼告诉他要遵守规则时——
So that you cannot wear.
那个是不能穿的。
--she knows him. He's the guy the union sends to argue its side. And these guys telling him he can't wear his jammers, they're management. This is a scantily clad labor dispute. I asked some other older lifeguards about this, and three out of the four of them agreed. This is about the union, which actually has a history of fighting age discrimination.
——她认识他。他是工会派出来辩论的那个人。而这些告诉他不能穿平角裤的家伙，是管理层。这是一场穿着暴露的劳资纠纷。我问过其他几位年长的救生员，四个人里有三个同意。这事关工会，而工会实际上有反抗年龄歧视的历史。
In 1966, they went on strike because the state tried to impose an age limit of 35 for Jones Beach lifeguards. So they walked off the beach. A week later, the state caved.
1966年，他们曾发起罢工，因为州政府试图对琼斯海滩救生员设置35岁的年龄上限。所以他们离开了海滩。一周后，州政府屈服了。
Knowing this, that the suits and the swimsuits have a history with each other, that helped me understand what Roy's fight was really about. Roy told me one reason he took a stand was that management was supposed to tell the union if they wanted to change a rule like this. And this time, they didn't.
了解了这些，知道这些制服和泳裤之间还有过一段历史，这让我明白了罗伊的抗争究竟是为了什么。罗伊告诉我，他站出来的部分原因是，管理层如果想改规则，理应通知工会。但这一次，他们没有。
Roy's got a weekend job now at a private beach club, but it's not the same.
罗伊现在在一家私人海滩俱乐部有份周末工作，但感觉不一样。
I like where I'm working now. I really do. But you get one rescue a year if you're lucky. And then it's what's called a puddle jumper.
我喜欢我现在工作的地方。真的。但你一年能遇上一次救援就不错了。而且那通常被称为“水坑跳跃者”（puddle jumper）。
What is a puddle jumper?
什么是“水坑跳跃者”？
A puddle jumper is where you really don't even need to get your head wet. And at Jones Beach, in the old days, we would have these tremendous rescues, just these great rescues.
“水坑跳跃者”就是那种你连头都不用弄湿的救援。在琼斯海滩，过去我们会有那种惊心动魄的救援，非常棒的救援。
His friends from Jones Beach tease him that he's in exile now.
他在琼斯海滩的朋友嘲笑他现在是在流亡。
How often do you go visit them?
你多久回去看他们一次？
Not that often. I keep in touch with them constantly. But I don't go down there that often. To be honest, it does hurt. It hurts to go down there. That was my beach. It was my home for so many years.
没那么频繁。我一直和他们保持联系。但我没那么常去那里。老实说，这很伤人。去那里让我心痛。那是我的海滩。那是我多年的家。
If Roy's theory is true, then the state is trying to get rid of the older lifeguards on Long Island by forcing them into Speedos. But if that's true, as far as I can tell, the only lifeguard they've managed to get rid of is Roy.
如果罗伊的理论是真的，那么州政府是在通过强迫他们穿三角泳裤来试图赶走长岛的老救生员。但如果那是真的，据我所知，他们成功赶走的唯一救生员只有罗伊。
Dani Chivvis is one of the producers of our program. Since we first broadcast this story, Roy is back at Jones Beach. After 12 years of fighting them over his right not to wear Speedos, New York state has granted him an exception. He passed his test, and he's back working as a lifeguard. He is 73 years old.
达娜·奇维斯是我们节目的制作人之一。自从我们首次播出这个故事后，罗伊已经回到了琼斯海滩。在为他不穿三角泳裤的权利斗争了12年之后，纽约州批准了他的例外申请。他通过了测试，回到了救生岗位。他现在73岁。
[MUSIC - "SPEEDO" BY THE CADILLACS]
[音乐 - The Cadillacs乐队《Speedo》]
Act Two, Beach Doctor.
第二幕，海滩医生。
Oh, hello? Yep, I'm here now.
哦，喂？是的，我在这儿。
Hey, Alex.
嘿，亚历克斯。
Hello, little buddy. How are you?
你好，小家伙。你好吗？
Hi, other little buddy.
你好，另一个小家伙。
This next story takes place on a beach in Mexico. Shane DuBow told it to producer Alex Blumberg a couple years ago. They're old friends.
下一个故事发生在墨西哥的海滩上。肖恩·杜博（Shane DuBow）几年前告诉了制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）。他们是老朋友了。
And basically as we were putting our show together, Alex remembered this thing that happened to Shane decades before when Shane was out kayaking on a trip in Mexico down in Baja, California. Shane and his friends took a month-long vacation. And every day, they would head out into the Gulf of California and go sea kayaking. They were really kind of in the middle of nowhere.
基本上在我们整理节目时，亚历克斯想起了几十年前肖恩身上发生的一件事。那时肖恩在墨西哥下加利福尼亚州的巴哈（Baja）划皮划艇旅行。肖恩和朋友们去度假一个月。每天他们都会划着海皮划艇进入加利福尼亚湾。他们基本上是在荒无人烟的地方。
There's little beach communities and some little tourist centers. But mostly what we were doing was finding deserted open beaches and camping. So there was nobody around for most of the time.
有些小海滩社区和旅游中心。但我们大部分时间都在寻找荒无人烟的开放海滩并露营。所以大部分时间周围根本没人。
Wow. So it was just like-- it was you, and there was like-- how many of them was it you said? Seven? Six, seven?
哇。所以就是——你们，你说有多少人来着？七个？六个，七个？
There was six or seven. And some people might go fishing. Some people might play cards. Some people might snorkel. I think we slept outside a lot. It felt like we were 12 years old, pretending to be Robinson Crusoe living off the land. So we carried all our own water, all our own food, camping supplies, tents, sleeping bags, cooking supplies,
六七个人吧。有些人去钓鱼，有些人玩牌，有些人浮潜。我想我们睡在外面很多。感觉就像我们是12岁的孩子，假装自己是鲁滨逊在荒岛生活。我们背着自己所有的水、食物、露营用品、帐篷、睡袋、炊具。
Sunscreen, I hope.
防晒霜，我希望。
Sunscreen? No, we were young then. We just figured it would be fine.
防晒霜？没有，那时候我们年轻。我们觉得没问题。
[LAUGHS] Are you serious? You didn't bring any sunscreen?
[笑]你是认真的吗？你们没带防晒霜？
I'm sure I didn't.
我敢肯定没带。
So we're in Baja. We are on a layover, which means we are just camped somewhere, and we're not trying to kayak right now. And we've been clamming all day. And my neck locks up, and I can't turn my head to one side. And this is bad for lots of reasons. But when you're kayaking, you have to be able to paddle. You got to be able to use both arms.
我们在巴哈。我们正在中转停留，意思是只是找个地方露营，没打算划船。我们整天都在挖蛤蜊。然后我的脖子锁住了，一侧转不动了。这很糟糕，原因很多。但当你划皮划艇时，你必须能划桨。你得两只手都能用。
And this neck locking up, this is something that's happened to you periodically throughout your life.
脖子锁住，这是你一生中周期性发生的事情。
Yeah, this happens six to eight times a year. It usually lasts three or four days. But so no one wants to be stuck on the beach while I'm working out my neck for three or four days.
是的，这每年会发生六到八次。通常持续三四天。但没人想在我处理脖子问题的三四天里被困在海滩上。
So we had run into a little expat community on a beach pretty close to where we were camping, these folks who were living in campers and had set up little cantinas, which are really just sort of stakes with a tarp over them. And they would serve beers, or, in our case, they showed us how to clam. And then they made us a clam feast.
所以我们在营地附近碰到了一个外籍人士社区，住在房车里的家伙，搭建了小酒馆，其实就是几根木桩搭块布。他们供应啤酒，或者在我们这个例子里，教我们怎么挖蛤蜊。然后给我们做了一顿蛤蜊大餐。
So we went back to the guy that had shown us how to do that, to his camper on the beach. And I said, there's not any chiropractors anywhere nearby, which was just a ridiculous question because there was nothing nearby. I mean, this is where it kind of gets apocryphal, but is actually true, because he gets this sort of wistful look in his eye, and he says, no, there's no chiropractor. But there is an amateur chiropractor who helps some of the local people. And his name is Johnny Tequila. And he lives on a boat two coves over from where you're staying. And if you go to this man, he may help you. It was very mystical.
所以我们回去找那个教我们怎么做的人，到他海滩边的房车里。我说，附近有没有脊椎按摩师？这是一个愚蠢的问题，因为附近什么都没有。然后事情开始变得带有传奇色彩，但却是真的，因为他眼里露出一丝渴望，说，不，没有脊椎按摩师。但有一位业余脊椎按摩师帮助过一些当地人。他的名字叫“龙舌兰约翰尼”（Johnny Tequila）。他住在你们营地两个海湾远的一条船上。如果你去找这个人，他可能会帮你。听起来很神秘。
And you were like, well, you had me at amateur chiropractor, but once I find out that his name is Dr. Johnny Tequila--
你当时的反应是，好吧，你提到“业余脊椎按摩师”就已经让我动心了，但当我发现他叫“龙舌兰约翰尼医生”时——
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
So you said, how do you get there?
所以你问，怎么去那儿？
How do I get there? I don't want to miss it. And he's like, you won't miss it. I was like, well, tell me where he is. And so he grabs a bar napkin and in black ballpoint pen, I think, sketches me a rough outline of the coast, and puts an X. There's an X marks the spot. That's where Johnny Tequila is two coves over. No one wants to go with me. They're all going to chill out, play cards.
怎么去那儿？我不想错过。他说，你不会错过的。我问，告诉我他在哪儿。于是他抓起一张酒吧餐巾纸，用黑色圆珠笔草草画了海岸线轮廓，画了个X。X标志着地点。那就是“龙舌兰约翰尼”所在的地方，两个海湾远。没人想跟我去。他们都想在那休息、玩牌。
Oh, so you had to kayak up to this guy?
噢，所以你必须划皮划艇去找这个家伙？
Yes, so I have to kayak to him.
是的，我得划皮划艇去找他。
I see.
明白了。
My friends had taken to teasing me about my paddle stroke, which was at this point one-armed and half-crippled, and they were calling it the chicken wing.
我的朋友们开始嘲笑我的划桨动作，当时是一只手划，半残废，他们称之为“鸡翅式”。
Because of your neck.
因为你的脖子。
Because of my neck. So I chicken wing for two coves worth, maybe a mile paddle. And you're really close to the shore. And the beach is right on your right, and the open ocean is on your left. And you're chicken winging-- one cove, OK. And I'm looking at my-- and my napkin gets wet, so my map gets all destroyed, comes apart.
因为我的脖子。所以我就这样划了两个海湾远，大概一英里。你离岸边很近。右边是海滩，左边是开阔的大海。我划着“鸡翅式”——经过第一个海湾，还可以。我看着我的地图——然后我的餐巾纸湿了，地图全毁了，散开了。
Because the water is running down your paddle handle?
因为水顺着桨柄流下来了？
So I chicken wing on over. And there, in the second cove, is a catamaran in the middle of an empty cove. And I don't want you to get the idea that this is a harbor, or a dock, or anything man-made-- nothing around. And it's docked in the water maybe 20 or 30 yards from shore.
所以我划着“鸡翅式”继续走。在第二个海湾里，有一艘双体船。别以为这是个港口、码头或人工设施——周围什么都没有。它停在离岸边20到30码的水里。
And as I paddled closer, I don't see anyone. It's got a cabin. But the mast is up. No sail is up. And as I get closer and closer, I can see around the mast, lined up are empty Cuervo Gold tequila bottles, but kind of orderly. That was the weird thing. Usually, you don't associate empty tequila bottles with order, but these had been meticulously kind of lined up.
当我划近时，没看到人。它有一个船舱。桅杆竖着，没挂帆。当我越来越近，我看到桅杆周围整齐地摆放着空的快活龙舌兰（Cuervo Gold）瓶子。那才奇怪。通常你不会把空酒瓶和秩序联系在一起，但这瓶子摆得太讲究了。
Ringing the mast.
绕着桅杆。
Ringing the mast. And again, I'm paddling up on a boat in the middle of nowhere with no one else around. And I don't really know how to even start. And from some deep place, the word that comes to me is ahoy, which I've certainly never used in normal conversation.
绕着桅杆。再说一遍，我划船到荒无人烟的地方，周围没有人。我甚至不知道该怎么开口。从内心深处，我冒出一个词——“阿豪”（ahoy），我肯定从未在正常谈话里用过这个词。
So I say, ahoy. And from out of the cabin comes a completely naked woman. She looks American, and blond hair, tanned so deeply. It's like the tan that goes to your liver. It's just tan all the way through. Really muscly-- her shoulders looked like she was probably a rafting guide in Colorado.
我说，“阿豪”。从船舱里走出来一个完全裸体的女人。看起来是美国人，金发，晒得很深。那是那种晒到肝脏里的肤色，透着深色。肌肉发达——肩膀看起来像是科罗拉多州的漂流向导。
So she's completely naked and completely unfazed about being completely naked, just greets me and talks to me as if she were wearing clothes. And she's above me, so I'm just looking up at her being naked from my kayak, holding onto the side of their boat.
她完全裸体，也完全没因为裸体而感到不自在，像穿了衣服一样打招呼和我说话。她在船上，所以我只能从皮划艇上仰视她，握着船舷。
And I'm in my kayak. And I said, is Johnny Tequila here? And she's very nice. And she goes, no, he went to town for supplies, but he'll be back shortly. Why don't you wait until he comes back?
我在皮划艇里说，龙舌兰约翰尼在这儿吗？她很友善，说，没有，他去镇上买补给了，但很快就回来。为什么不在这儿等会儿呢？
And then eventually Johnny Tequila, we see him on the beach near us. And he's got a little rowboat. And he rows back to us. And he looks exactly like her. I mean, he's got on shorts, but he's got that tan. He looks kind of muscly in his shoulders and chest. And they both have kind of wild, bleached out blond hair and real scruffy-- maybe 30s, although the sun makes everyone look older, so who knows?
后来我们看到龙舌兰约翰尼在附近的海滩上。他有一艘小划艇。他划回来找我们。他看起来和她一模一样。我的意思是，他穿着短裤，但那种晒痕……他肩膀和胸部看起来很强壮。他们都有狂野、漂白过的金发，非常邋遢——可能是30多岁，尽管阳光让人看起来显老，谁知道呢？
And I tell him my story. And he's like, yeah, of course I'll perform some amateur chiropractory on your neck. He didn't say that. He said just, yeah, of course, I'll help you. Follow me to shore. So he rose, and I chicken wing to the shore. And we pull our boats up.
我告诉他我的故事。他说，当然，我会为你那脖子做点业余脊椎按摩。他没这么说。他说，没问题，当然，我会帮你。跟我去岸上。于是他划船，我“鸡翅式”划桨跟到岸上。我们把船拉上岸。
And then he said, follow me. And now we are going-- I want to say jungle, but it was not jungle. But it's dense scrub. I mean, there's bushes all around us. There's cacti winding around in the middle of Mexico with no one else for miles. And I'm following him on this path, a really faint path. And we come to a clearing.
他说，跟着我。我们现在正走向——我想说丛林，但那不是丛林。是茂密的灌木丛。到处是灌木。墨西哥中部到处是仙人掌，方圆几英里无人影。我跟着他走在这条很淡的小径上，真的非常难辨。我们来到一块空地。
And in the clearing there is a table exactly like a massage table or a chiropractic table you'd see in a real chiropractor's office with the center part that's open. And you can put your face down there, and the neck part articulates and comes up. It's the real deal. And a life-sized human skeleton hanging from a tree, which I assume is a replica, but it looks like it-- a skeleton and the table in a clearing in the middle of the desert in Mexico.
在那块空地上，有一张桌子，和你真的脊椎按摩师办公室里看到的按摩床或调节床一模一样，中间部分是可以打开的。你可以把脸放在那儿，脖子部分可以调节角度。这是真的。树上还挂着一个真人大小的人体骨骼，我想那是复制品，但这看起来很真——骨骼和桌子，在墨西哥沙漠中的一块空地上。
And then he has me lie on my back, looking up at his face and his crazy hair. And he's shirtless. Did I tell you my chiropractor was shirtless? He's shirtless. And he puts his hands around my neck in the middle of Mexico in a clearing with a skeleton. My amateur chiropractor now has my neck in his hands. And he gives me a chiropractic exam that resembles every other chiropractic exam I've received.
然后他让我仰躺着，看着他的脸和他疯狂的头发。他没穿上衣。我告诉过你我的按摩师没穿上衣吗？他没穿上衣。他在墨西哥的一块空地上，带着骨骼模型，把手放在我脖子上。我的业余脊椎按摩师现在用手托着我的脖子。他给我做了一次脊椎按摩检查，和他人的按摩检查一模一样。
And then he does an adjustment that also passes as any other chiropractic adjustment I've received. And I say, Johnny Tequila, thank you for adjusting my neck. Can I pay you? And he said, no. I just do this to help people. There will be no payment. But if you ever see me in a bar, you can buy me a shot of tequila.
然后他做了一次调整，也和其他调整无异。我说，龙舌兰约翰尼，谢谢你帮我调整脖子。我可以付钱吗？他说，不。我这么做只是为了帮助别人。不用付钱。但如果你以后在酒吧看到我，可以请我喝杯龙舌兰酒。
Then the next day, was, in fact, your neck better?
那么第二天，你的脖子真的好了吗？
Well, it's possible I'm collapsing time, but the way I remember it, I chicken wing back, and over the next few hours I start to feel much, much better. And my neck is OK.
可能我的记忆有点错乱，但我记得的是，我划着“鸡翅式”回去了，接下来的几个小时里，我开始感觉好多了。我的脖子没问题了。
Do you think that Johnny Tequila-- when you think of Johnny Tequila, is he an argument for chucking it all and moving to some quiet beach in some distant land, or is he an argument against it?
你觉得龙舌兰约翰尼——当你想到他时，他是那种“放弃一切去偏远土地的安静海滩”的论据，还是反面教材？
He's 100% an argument for. I can't believe you asked me that question. A simpler life-- just crack people's necks, drink tequila, sing in the cantina, and go home to my naked lady. Did I not tell the story to make it seem good? It seemed great.
他百分之百是正面例子。不敢相信你问我这个问题。更简单的生活——给人按按脖子，喝喝龙舌兰酒，在小酒馆唱唱歌，回家面对裸体的女士。我讲故事时没表现出那种好吗？看起来棒极了。
Shane DuBow talking to Alex Blumberg. Alex, by the way, has a brand new show that he is co-hosting. It's a podcast that launches next week. It's called How to Save a Planet, about climate solutions, on August 20. Look for it wherever you get your podcasts.
肖恩·杜博接受亚历克斯·布隆伯格采访。顺便提一下，亚历克斯有个新节目正由他共同主持。这是一个下周即将发布的播客。叫做《如何拯救星球》（How to Save a Planet），关于气候解决方案，8月20日发布。在任何你获取播客的地方都可以找到。
[MUSIC - "JOHNNY" BY AB AND THE SEA]
[音乐 - AB and the Sea乐队《Johnny》]
Act Three, The Beachcomber. OK, so the absolute beachiest radio show, I think, maybe that has ever been made-- I believe, anyway-- was done by my first boss at NPR, this documentary producer named Keith Talbot. He made this back in 1979. It was called Ocean Hour.
第三幕，沙滩拾荒者。好的，我觉得有史以来最能体现海滩风情的电台节目——至少我认为是——是我在NPR的第一任老板、 documentary制作人基思·塔尔博特（Keith Talbot）做的。那是1979年的节目。叫《海洋小时》（Ocean Hour）。
And I love that show. Like I say, I think it's the beachiest radio show mankind will ever produce. And here is one of my favorite parts. Before I play this, I should say, this is such a piece of 1970s-era public radio that there's no narration on the show giving the name of the interviewee who you're about to hear or where he is. That's how we rolled back then. Anyway, I hope you like this.
我喜欢那个节目。就像我说的那样，我认为这是人类制作过的最有海滩气息的电台节目。这是我最喜欢的片段之一。播放之前我得说明一下，这简直就是70年代公共广播的典范，节目里没有旁白介绍接下来的受访者是谁，也不知道他在哪里。那时候我们就是这么做的。总之，希望你喜欢。
Here is a scrounger's life, just like a beachcomber. I have lived as poor as a man can live and still survive in the United States of America in the 1970s because everything comes here somehow sooner or later-- wood, oysters, the various other fish that you can get for the asking-- mullet, which is the big, good eating fish around here, along with trout and catfish, which come from the rivers. You have the river cat and the saltwater cat. They seem to be cousins, but they taste a little different.
这就是拾荒者的生活，就像个沙滩拾荒者。我活得像个穷人，但还能在70年代的美国生存，因为无论迟早，所有东西都会飘到这儿来——木头、牡蛎、其他你伸手可得的鱼类——比如鲻鱼，那是这里很好的食用鱼，还有河流里的鳟鱼和鲶鱼。你有河鲶和海鲶。它们看起来是表亲，但味道有点不同。
And in addition to all of that, you get the kinds of things that the sea brings, which is from boats. There's always a certain amount of movement of cargo in boats, as well as fish. And firewood around here is for the asking. In a city like New York or Washington, firewood, I'm sure, costs $100 a truckload, $200. Around here, you can go out and fill it up for nothing.
除了这些，你还能得到大海带来的东西，来自船只。船上有货运的流动，也有鱼。这附近的木柴随处可见。在纽约或华盛顿这样的城市，我敢肯定木柴要卖到100或200美元一卡车。在这里，你可以去捡，装满也不要钱。
There is a theory, for example, in archaeology that all of the early settlements were on the coast of man, that that's where the easiest life has always been, where everything was for the taking. And you had the sea, and you had the land together, and the various mutations between them. And that's where food chains like to start, where you have that melting land or that solidifying water. That's where the organisms get their start, especially if you have the right climate.
比如考古学有个理论，认为所有早期定居点都在海岸线上，那是人类最容易生存的地方，那里一切应有尽有。你拥有大海，你拥有陆地，以及它们之间的各种变异。这是食物链喜欢开始的地方，那是融化的陆地或凝固的海水。生命有机体就是在那里开始的，特别是在气候适宜的地方。
As a poor man, it means that things are coming to me, which don't happen very much on the prairie or in the big cities. Nothing comes to your door in a big city except a cop, or a taxi driver, or something. But here, things actually come to your door.
作为一个穷人，这意味着东西会自动找上门，这在大草原或大城市里可不会发生。在大城市，除了警察或出租车司机，什么都不会找上门。但在这里，东西真的会送到门口。
An excerpt from Ocean Hour in 1979. A link to that entire program is at our website, and I do recommend it. It's thisamericanlife.org. Coming up, David Sedaris and his family go to the beach, except for one of them. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
《海洋小时》1979年的片段。完整节目的链接在我们网站上，我推荐去听听。网站是thisamericanlife.org。接下来，大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）和他的家人去海滩，除了其中一个。节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, for everybody who is far from the beach, for everybody who's avoiding the beach because of coronavirus, for everybody who needs the beach, we take you there with stories about the beach. We've arrived at Act Four-- Act Four, Now We Are Five.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，为了每一个远离海滩的人，为了每一个因新冠肺炎而避开海滩的人，为了每一个需要海滩的人，我们用关于海滩的故事带你去那里。我们进入了第四幕——第四幕，我们现在是五个人。
OK, so if you're a beach family, you go to the beach every year. Good years, bad years, whatever happens in your family that year, it's just what you do. David Sedaris has this story about his family heading to the beach together one year. This was first published in The New Yorker a few years back. And here at our program, we all really loved it. So here's David.
好的，如果你是一个爱去海滩的家庭，你每年都会去。不管好年头坏年头，无论家里发生了什么，这就是你们的做法。大卫·塞达里斯有一个关于他家人某年一起去海滩的故事。这篇故事几年前首次刊登在《纽约客》上。在我们节目组，大家都特别喜欢。所以，有请大卫。
In late May of last year, a few weeks shy of her 50th birthday, my youngest sister, Tiffany, committed suicide. She was living in a room in a beat-up house on the hard side of Somerville, Massachusetts and had been dead, the coroner guessed, for at least five days before her door was battered down. I was given the news over a white courtesy phone while at the Dallas airport. Then, because my plane to Baton Rouge was boarding and I wasn't sure what else to do, I got on it.
去年五月下旬，在我最小的妹妹蒂芙尼（Tiffany）50岁生日前几周，她自杀身亡了。她住在马萨诸塞州萨默维尔（Somerville）贫民区一间破败房子的单间里，验尸官推测，在她房门被撞开之前，她已经去世至少五天了。我在达拉斯机场收到消息，手里还拿着白色礼宾电话。随后，因为我去巴吞鲁日的航班正在登机，我不知道还能做什么，于是还是登机了。
The following morning, I boarded another plane, this one to Atlanta. And the day after that, I flew to Nashville, thinking all the while about my ever-shrinking family. A person expects his parents to die, but a sibling? I felt I'd lost the identity I'd enjoyed since 1968 when my brother was born.
次日，我又登上了去亚特兰大的飞机。之后的一天，我飞往纳什维尔，脑子里一直在想我那日益缩小的家庭。人总是预期父母会去世，但兄弟姐妹呢？我觉得我失去了一种身份认同，自从1968年我弟弟出生后我就一直拥有的身份认同。
"Six kids!" people would say. "How do your poor folks manage?"
“六个孩子！”人们常说。“你们可怜的父母是怎么管理的？”
There were a lot of big families in the neighborhood I grew up in. Every other house was a fiefdom, so I never gave it much thought until I became an adult and my friends started having children. One or two seemed reasonable, but anything beyond that struck me as outrageous. A couple Hugh and I knew in Normandy would occasionally come to dinner with their wrecking crew of three. When they'd leave several hours later, every last part of me would feel violated.
我长大的社区有很多大家庭。每家每户都像是小王国，所以我从来没多想，直到我成年且朋友们开始生孩子。一两个似乎合理，但再多就让我觉得过分了。我和休（Hugh）在诺曼底认识的一对夫妇偶尔会带着他们那三个破坏狂来吃晚饭。当他们几小时后离开时，我的每一根神经都感到被侵犯了。
Take those kids, double them, and subtract the cable TV-- that's what my parents had to deal with. Now, though, there weren't six, only five. "And you can't really say, 'There used to be six,'" I told my sister, Lisa. "It just makes people uncomfortable."
把这些孩子翻倍，再减掉有线电视——那就是我父母要面对的情况。但现在，不是六个了，只有五个。“而且你不能真的说，‘以前有六个，’”我对我姐姐丽莎（Lisa）说。“那只会让人们感到不舒服。”
I recalled a father and son I'd met in California a few years back.
我想起几年前在加州遇到的一个父亲和儿子。
"So are there other children?" I asked.
“还有其他孩子吗？”我问。
"There are," the man said. "Three who are living and a daughter, Chloe, who died before she was born, 18 years ago."
“有，”那个男人说。“三个在世，还有一个女儿克洛伊（Chloe），18年前在出生前就去世了。”
That's not fair, I remember thinking. Because, I mean, what's a person supposed to do with that?
这不公平，我记得我当时想。因为，我的意思是，一个人该怎么面对那种事？
Compared to most 49-year-olds or even most 49-month-olds, Tiffany didn't have much. She did leave a will, though. In it, she decreed that we, her family, could not have her body or attend her memorial service.
与大多数49岁甚至49个月大的人相比，蒂芙尼没留下什么。不过她留下了遗嘱。在遗嘱中，她下令我们这些家人不得认领她的遗体，也不得参加她的追悼会。
"So put that in your pipe and smoke it," her mother would have said.
“那你把这记在心里吧，”她妈妈本会这么说。
A few days after getting the news, my sister, Amy, drove to Somerville with a friend and collected two boxes of things from Tiffany's room-- family photos, many of which had been ripped into pieces, comment cards from a neighborhood grocery store, notebooks, receipts. The bed, a mattress on the floor, had been taken away, and a large industrial fan had been set up. Amy snapped some pictures while she was there. And individually and in groups, those of us left studied them for clues-- a paper plate on a dresser that had several drawers missing, a phone number written on a wall, a collection of mop handles, each one a different color, arranged like cattails in a barrel painted green.
收到消息几天后，我姐姐艾米（Amy）和朋友开车去了萨默维尔，从蒂芙尼的房间收集了两箱东西——家庭照片，很多都被撕成了碎片，当地一家杂货店的意见卡，笔记本，收据。那张铺在地板上的床垫被移走了，留下了一个大号工业风扇。艾米在那里拍了一些照片。我们这些留下的人，单独或分组研究它们，试图寻找线索——梳妆台上的纸盘子缺了好几个抽屉，墙上写着电话号码，一堆不同颜色的拖把杆，像桶里的香蒲一样排列着，桶被漆成了绿色。
Six months before our sister killed herself, I had made plans for us all to gather at a beach house on Emerald Isle off the coast of North Carolina. My family used to vacation there every summer, but after my mother died we stopped going-- not because we lost interest, but because it was she who always made the arrangements and, more importantly, paid for it. The place I found with the help of my sister-in-law, Kathy, had six bedrooms and a small swimming pool. Our week-long rental period began on Saturday, June 8, and we arrived to find a delivery woman standing in the driveway with seven pounds of seafood, a sympathy gift sent by friends. "There's slaw in there too," she said, handing over the bags.
在我们姐妹自杀前六个月，我计划全家人在北卡罗来纳海岸外的翡翠岛（Emerald Isle）聚会。我们家以前每年夏天都去那里度假，但在母亲去世后我们就不去了——不是因为没兴趣，而是因为一直以来都是她负责安排，更重要的是，她负责付钱。在嫂子凯茜（Kathy）的帮助下，我找到的地方有六间卧室和一个小游泳池。我们为期一周的租赁期从6月8日星期六开始，我们到达时，发现一位送货员站在车道上，带着七磅海鲜，是朋友们寄来的慰问礼物。“里面还有凉拌卷心菜，”她递过袋子时说。
In the past, when my family rented a cottage, my sisters and I would crowd the door like puppies around a food dish. Our father would unlock it, and we'd tear through the house, claiming rooms. I always picked the biggest one facing the ocean. And just as I'd start to unpack, my parents would enter and tell me that this was theirs. "I mean, just who the hell do you think you are?" my father would ask.
过去，当家里租小屋时，我和姐妹们会像 puppies 围绕食盆一样挤在门口。父亲会打开门，我们就会冲进屋子抢房间。我总是选朝向大海最大的那一间。正当我准备打开行李时，父母就会进来告诉我那是他们的。“我的意思是，你以为你是谁？”父亲会问。
He and my mother would move in, and I would get booted to what was called the maid's room. It was always on the ground level, a kind of dank shed next to where the car was parked. There was never an interior stairway leading to the upper floor. Instead, I had to take the outside steps and, more often than not, knock on the locked front door, like a beggar hoping to be invited in.
他和母亲会搬进去，我则会被踢到所谓的“女佣房”。那总是在底层，紧挨着停车处的一个阴暗棚屋。里面从来没有通往楼上的楼梯。相反，我必须走外面的台阶，而且通常必须敲锁上的前门，就像一个希望被邀请进去的乞丐。
"What do you want?" my sisters would ask.
“你想要什么？”姐妹们会问。
"I want to come inside."
“我想进去。”
"That's funny," Lisa, the eldest, would say to the others, who were gathered like disciples around her. "Did you hear something, a whining sound? What is it that makes a noise like that? A hermit crab? A little sea slug?"
“那真有趣，”丽莎，老大，会对围在她身边的其他人说。“你们听到了什么吗，一种呜咽声？什么东西会发出那种声音？寄居蟹？小海蛞蝓？”
Normally, there was a social divide between the three oldest and three youngest children in my family. Lisa, Gretchen, and I treated the others like servants and did very well for ourselves. At the beach, though, all bets were off, and it was just upstairs against downstairs, meaning everyone against me.
通常，我家三胞兄姐和三胞幼弟之间会有社交鸿沟。丽莎、格雷琴（Gretchen）和我对待其他人就像佣人一样。但在海滩上，一切都不一样了，变成了楼上对抗楼下，意味着所有人对抗我。
This time, because I was paying, I got to choose the best room. Amy moved in next door, and my brother, Paul, his wife, and their 10-year-old daughter, Maddy, took the spot next to her. That was it for oceanfront. The others arrived later and had to take the leftovers. Lisa's room faced the street, as did my father's. Gretchen's faced the street and was intended for someone who was paralyzed. Hanging from the ceiling were electric pulleys designed to lift a harnessed body into and out of bed.
这一次，因为是我付钱，我选了最好的房间。艾米搬进了隔壁，我弟弟保罗（Paul）、他的妻子以及他们10岁的女儿麦迪（Maddy）住在他旁边。海景房就这些了。其他人后来才到，只能选剩下的。丽莎的房间朝街，父亲的也是。格雷琴的房间也朝街，原本是为瘫痪者准备的。天花板上挂着电动滑轮，设计用于把瘫痪者吊着上下床。
Unlike the cottages of our youth, this one did not have a maid's room. It was too new and fancy for that, as were the homes that surrounded it. Traditionally, all the island houses were on stilts, but more and more often now the ground floors are filled in. They all have beachy names and are painted beachy colors. But most of those built after Hurricane Fran hit the coast in 1996 are three stories tall and look almost suburban.
不像我们儿时的小屋，这一间没有女佣房。它太新太高级了，周围的房子也是。传统上，岛上的房子都架在桩子上，但现在地面层被填满的情况越来越常见。它们都有海滩气息的名字，漆着海滩颜色。但1996年飓风弗兰（Hurricane Fran）袭击海岸后建造的房子大多数都有三层楼高，看起来几乎像郊区的住宅。
This place was vast and airy. The kitchen table sat 12, and there was not one but two dishwashers. All the pictures were ocean related-- seascapes and lighthouses, all with the airborne V's that are shorthand for seagull. A sampler on the living room wall read, "Old shellers never die. They simply conch out." On the round clock beside it, the numbers lay in an indecipherable heap, as if they had come unglued. Just above them were printed the words, "Who cares?"
这地方宽敞通风。厨房桌子坐12个人，有两个洗碗机。所有的图片都与海洋有关——海景和灯塔，全都有象征海鸥的空中小V符号。客厅墙上的采样画写着：“老拾壳者永不消逝。他们只是conch out（谐音双关，意为‘搞砸/撤退’）。”旁边的圆形时钟上，数字堆放得乱七八糟，仿佛粘合剂失效了。在它们上方写着：“谁在乎？”
This was what we found ourselves saying whenever anyone asked the time.
每当有人问时间时，我们发现自己都在说这个。
"Who cares?"
“谁在乎？”
The day before we arrived at the beach, Tiffany's obituary ran in the Raleigh News and Observer. It was submitted by Gretchen, who stated that our sister had passed away peacefully at her home. This made it sound as if she were very old and had a house, but what else could you do? People were leaving responses on the paper's website, and one fellow wrote that Tiffany used to come into the video store where he worked in Somerville. When his glasses broke, she offered him a pair she had found while foraging for art supplies in somebody's trash can. He said she also gave him a Playboy magazine from the 1960s that included a photo spread titled "The Ass Menagerie."
在到达海滩的前一天，蒂芙尼的讣告登在《罗利新闻与观察家报》（Raleigh News and Observer）上。这是格雷琴提交的，她称我们姐妹是在家中平静离世的。这听起来好像她很老而且有自己的房子，但还能怎么办呢？人们在报纸网站上留下回复，一个家伙写道，蒂芙尼过去常去他工作的那家萨默维尔视频店。当他的眼镜碎了时，她给了他一副她在别人垃圾桶里找艺术品材料时发现的眼镜。他说她还给过他一本1960年代的《花花公子》杂志，里面有一张题为“屁股动物园”的照片专栏。
This was fascinating, as we didn't really know our sister very well. Each of us had pulled away from the family at some point in our lives. We'd had to in order to forge our own identities, to go from being a Sedaris to our own specific Sedaris. Tiffany, though, stayed away. She might promise to come home for Christmas, but at the last minute there'd always be some excuse-- she missed her plane, she had to work. The same would happen with our summer vacations. "The rest of us managed to make it," I'd say, aware of how old and guilt trippy I sounded.
这太令人着迷了，因为我们其实不太了解这个姐妹。我们每个人都在人生某个时刻远离过家庭。我们必须这样做才能建立自己的认同，才能从一个“塞达里斯”（Sedaris）变成具体的某一个塞达里斯。但蒂芙尼选择了彻底远离。她可能承诺圣诞节回家，但最后关头总会找借口——错过了航班、必须工作。暑假度假也一样。“我们其他人都能做到，”我会说，意识到我听起来有多老气横秋和令人愧疚。
All of us would be disappointed by her absence, though for different reasons. Even if you weren't getting along with Tiffany at the time, you couldn't deny the show she put on-- the dramatic entrances, the non-stop, professional-grade insults, the chaos she'd inevitably leave in her wake. One day she'd throw a dish at you and the next she'd create a mosaic made of the shards. When allegiances with one brother or sister flamed out, she'd take up with someone else. At no time did she get along with everybody, but there was always someone she was in contact with. Toward the end, it was Lisa, but before that we'd all had our turn.
我们所有人都会对她的缺席感到失望，尽管原因各不相同。即使你当时和蒂芙尼合不来，你也不能否认她上演的那些戏码——戏剧性的入场、不间断的专业级侮辱、她不可避免会留下的混乱。今天她可能向你扔盘子，明天她会用碎片拼出马赛克艺术。当和某位兄弟姐妹的盟友关系破裂时，她会转向另一个人。她从没能和所有人处好关系，但她总是在和某个人保持联系。临近最后，那是丽莎，但在那之前，我们每个人都轮到过。
The last time she joined us on Emerald Isle was 1986. "And even then, she left after three days," Gretchen reminded us.
她最后一次在翡翠岛加入我们是1986年。“即使那样，她三天后也走了，”格雷琴提醒我们。
As kids, we spent our beach time swimming. Then we became teenagers and devoted ourselves to tanning. There's a certain kind of talk that takes place when you're lying, dazed in the sun, and I've always been partial to it. On the first afternoon of our most recent trip, we laid out one of the bedspreads we had as children and arranged ourselves side by side on it, trading stories about Tiffany.
小时候，我们花时间在海滩游泳。后来我们成了青少年，开始致力于晒黑。当你昏昏沉沉地躺在阳光下时，总会进行某种特定的谈话，我一直很喜欢那种感觉。我们最近这次旅行的第一天下午，我们铺开了儿时用过的床单，肩并肩躺在一起，交换着关于蒂芙尼的故事。
"What about the Halloween she spent on that Army base?"
“还记得她在那个陆军基地过的那个万圣节吗？”
"And the time she showed up at Dad's birthday party with a black eye?"
“还有她带着黑眼圈出现在爸爸生日派对的那次？”
"I remember this girl she met years ago at a party," I began, when my turn came. "She'd been talking about facial scars and how terrible it would be to have one, so Tiffany said, 'I have a little scar on my face, and I don't think it's so awful.' 'Well,' the girl said, 'you would if you were pretty.'"
“我记得她几年前在派对上认识的一个女孩，”轮到我时我开始说。“她一直在谈论脸上的伤疤以及长伤疤有多可怕，于是蒂芙尼说，‘我脸上也有点小伤疤，我觉得没那么糟糕。’‘嗯，’那个女孩说，‘如果你长得漂亮，你就会这么觉得了。’”
Amy laughed and rolled over onto her stomach. Oh, that's a good line. I rearranged the towel I was using as a pillow. Isn't it, though? Coming from someone else, the story might have been upsetting, but not being pretty was never one of Tiffany's problems, especially when she was in her 20s and 30s, and men tumbled helpless before her.
艾米笑了，翻了个身趴在肚子上。“噢，那句真经典。”我重新摆弄了当枕头用的毛巾。“不是吗？如果换个人说，这个故事可能让人沮丧，但‘长得不漂亮’从来不是蒂芙尼的问题，特别是当她20多岁和30多岁时，男人们在她面前简直束手无策。”
"Funny," I said, "but I don't remember a scar on her face."
“奇怪，”我说，“我不记得她脸上有什么伤疤。”
I stayed in the sun too long that day and got a burn on my forehead. That was basically it for me and the beach blanket. I made brief appearances for the rest of the week, stopping to dry off after a swim, but mainly I spent my days on a bike, cycling up and down the coast and thinking about what had happened.
那天我在阳光下待得太久，前额晒伤了。对于海滩毯子来说，我基本上就到此为止了。那周剩下的时间我偶尔露个面，游完泳停下来擦干身体，但我大部分时间都在骑车，沿着海岸骑行，思考着发生过的事情。
While the rest of us seemed to get along effortlessly, with Tiffany it always felt like work. She and I usually made up after arguing, but our last fight took it out of me. And at the time of her death, we hadn't spoken in eight years. During that period, I regularly found myself near Somerville. And though I'd always toy with the idea of contacting her, I never did, despite my father's encouragement.
当我们其他人似乎能轻松相处时，和蒂芙尼在一起总是感觉很费力。我们吵架后通常会和好，但最后一次争吵让我筋疲力尽。在她去世时，我们已经八年没说话了。在那段时间里，我经常出现在萨默维尔附近。虽然我总是想联系她，但我从未这样做，尽管父亲鼓励我。
Meanwhile, I'd get reports from him and Lisa. Tiffany had lost her apartment, had gone on disability, had moved into a room found for her by a social service agency. Perhaps she was more forthcoming with her friends, but her family got things only in bits and pieces. She didn't talk with us so much as at us, great blocks of speech that were in turns funny, astute, and so contradictory, it was hard to connect the sentence you were hearing to the one that preceded it. Before we stopped speaking, I could always tell when she was on the phone. I'd walk into the house and hear Hugh say, "Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh."
与此同时，我会从父亲和丽莎那里得到消息。蒂芙尼失去了公寓，申请了残疾补贴，搬进了一家社会服务机构为她找的房间。也许她和朋友们更坦诚，但家里人只能零星地得到消息。她不是和我们谈话，而是对着我们说话，一大段一大段的言辞，时而有趣、时而精明，又充满矛盾，很难把你说的那句话和上一句联系起来。在我们停止说话之前，我总能听出她什么时候在电话里。我会走进屋子，听到休说，“嗯哼，嗯哼，嗯哼。”
In addition to the two boxes that Amy had filled in Somerville, she also brought down our sister's 1978 ninth grade yearbook. Among the messages inscribed by her classmates was the following, written by someone who had drawn a marijuana leaf beside her name. "Tiffany, you are a one-of-a-kind girl, so stay that way, you unique ass. I'm only sorry we couldn't have partied more together. This school sucks to hell. Stay cool, stoned, drunk, [BLEEP] up. Check your ass later." Then there's, "Tiffany, I'm looking forward to getting high with you this summer," and, "Tiffany, call me sometime this summer, and we'll go out and get blitzed."
除了艾米在萨默维尔填满的两箱东西外，她还带下了我们姐妹的1978年九年级毕业纪念册。在同学们题写的寄语中，有这么一条，写字的人还在她名字旁边画了一片大麻叶。“蒂芙尼，你是独一无二的女孩，保持那样，你这个独特的混蛋。很抱歉我们不能一起多聚聚。这学校烂透了。保持酷、吸毒、喝醉，[消音]搞乱。回头见。”接着是，“蒂芙尼，我期待着这个夏天和你一起嗨，”还有，“蒂芙尼，这个夏天打给我，我们要出去喝个烂醉。”
A few weeks after these messages were written, Tiffany ran away and was subsequently sent to a disciplinary institution in Maine called Elan. According to what she told us later, it was a horrible place. She returned home in 1980, having spent two years there. And from that point on, none of us can recall a conversation in which she did not mention it. She blamed the family for sending her off, but we, her siblings, had nothing to do with it. Paul, for instance-- Paul was 10 when she left. I was 21.
写下这些留言几周后，蒂芙尼离家出走，随后被送往缅因州一家名为埃兰（Elan）的纪律机构。据她后来告诉我们的，那是个可怕的地方。她于1980年回到家，在那儿待了两年。从那以后，我们谁也记不起她在哪里不提这件事。她指责家里人把她送走，但我们这些兄弟姐妹和那件事无关。比如保罗——她走的时候保罗才10岁。我21岁。
For a year, I sent her monthly letters. Then she wrote and told me to stop. As for my parents, there were only so many times they could apologize. We had other kids, they said in their defense. You think we could let the world stop on account of any one of you?
有一年，我每月给她写信。然后她写信让我停止。至于我父母，他们道歉的次数已经够多了。我们还有其他孩子，他们辩解说。你们以为我们能为了你们中的任何一个让世界停转吗？
We were at the beach for three days before Lisa and our father, who is now 90, joined us. Being on the island meant missing the spinning classes he takes in Raleigh, so I found a fitness center not far from the rental cottage, and every afternoon he and I would spend some time there. On the way over, we talked to each other, but as soon as we mounted our stationary bikes we'd each retreat into our own thoughts. It was a small place, not very lively. A mute television oversaw the room, tuned to the weather channel and reminding us that there's always a catastrophe somewhere or other, always someone flooded from his home or running for his life from a funnel-shaped cloud.
我们在海滩待了三天，丽莎和我们90岁的父亲才加入。留在岛上意味着错过他在罗利上的普拉提课，所以我找了一家离租赁小屋不远的健身中心，每天下午我和他都会花些时间在那儿。去那儿的路上，我们会互相交谈，但一旦跨上固定单车，我们就会退回到各自的思想中。那是个很小的地方，不太热闹。一台静音电视监控着房间，调到了天气频道，提醒我们哪里总有灾难，总有人被洪水淹没家园，或者在漏斗状云层下逃命。
Toward the end of the week, I came upon my father in Amy's room, sifting through the photos that Tiffany had destroyed. In his hand was a fragment of my mother's head with a patch of blue sky behind her. Under what circumstances had this been ripped up, I wondered. It seemed such a melodramatic gesture, like throwing a glass against a wall, something someone in a movie would do.
那周快结束时，我在艾米房间发现了父亲，正在翻看蒂芙尼毁掉的照片。他手里拿着母亲头像的碎片，背后是一片蓝天。在什么情况下这些会被撕碎，我心想。这姿态太戏剧化了，就像把杯子砸在墙上，那是电影里的人才会做的事。
"Just awful," my father whispered. "A person's life reduced to one lousy box."
“真糟，”父亲低声说。“一个人的生活竟然被缩减到了一个破箱子里。”
I put my hand on his shoulder. "Actually, there are two of them."
我把手放在他肩膀上。“实际上，有两个。”
He corrected himself-- "Two lousy boxes."
他更正道——“两个破箱子。”
One afternoon on Emerald Isle, we all rode to the Food Lion for groceries. I was in the produce department looking at red onions when my brother sneaked up from behind and let loose with a loud achoo, this while whipping a bouquet of wet parsley through the air. I felt the spray on the back of my neck and froze, thinking a very sick stranger had just sneezed on me. It's a neat trick, but he also doused the Indian woman who was standing to my left. She was wearing a blood-colored sari, so got it on her bare arm as well as her neck and the lower part of her back.
翡翠岛的一个下午，我们全家去Food Lion超市买杂货。我正在农产品区看红洋葱，我弟弟从背后溜过来，大声打了个喷嚏，同时把一束湿欧芹在空中挥舞。我感觉到脖子后面有喷溅物，愣住了，心想一个病得很重的陌生人刚对着我打喷嚏。这真是个绝活，但他也喷到了我左边的那位印度女士身上。她穿着血红色的纱丽，所以喷溅物不仅弄脏了她的裸露手臂，还弄脏了脖子和背部下方。
"Sorry, man," Paul said when she turned around, horrified. "I was just playing a joke on my brother."
“抱歉，哥们，”保罗在她惊恐地转过身时说。“我只是和我哥哥开了个玩笑。”
The woman had many thin bracelets on, and they jangled as she brushed her hand against the back of her head.
那位女士戴着许多细手镯，当她擦拭后脑勺时，手镯发出叮当声。
"You called her man," I said to him after she walked off.
“你叫她哥们，”我在她走开后对他说道。
"For real?" he asked.
“真的吗？”他问。
Amy mimicked him perfectly-- "For real?"
艾米完美地模仿了他——“真的吗？”
Over the phone, my brother, like me, is often mistaken for a woman. As we continued shopping, he told us that his van had recently broken down and that when he called for a tow truck the dispatcher said, "We'll be right out, sweetie." He lowered a watermelon into the cart and turned to his daughter. "Maddy's got a daddy who talks like a lady, but she don't care, do she?"
在电话里，我弟弟像我一样，经常被误认为女性。当我们继续购物时，他告诉我们他的货车最近抛锚了，当他叫拖车时，调度员说，“马上就到，甜心。”他把一个西瓜放进购物车，转向女儿。“麦迪的爸爸说话像个女士，但她不在乎，对吧？”
Giggling, she punched him in the stomach, and I was struck by how comfortable the two of them are with each other. Our father was a figure of authority, while Paul is more of a playmate.
咯咯笑着，她往他肚子上捶了一拳，他们俩在一起的那种舒适感让我印象深刻。父亲是权威的象征，而保罗更像个玩伴。
When we went to the beach as children, on or about the fourth day our father would say, "Wouldn't it be nice to buy a cottage down here?" We'd get our hopes up, and then he would bring practical concerns into it. They weren't petty. Buying a house that will eventually get blown away by a hurricane probably isn't the best way to spend your money, but still we wanted one desperately.
小时候我们去海滩，大约第四天左右父亲会说，“在这里买个小屋不是很好吗？”我们会满怀希望，然后他会提出实际问题。它们并不琐碎。买一个最终会被飓风吹走的房子大概不是花钱的最佳方式，但我们依然迫切地想要一个。
I told myself when I was young that one day I would buy a beach house, and then it would be everyone's, as long as they followed my Draconian rules and never stopped thanking me for it. Thus it was on Wednesday morning, midway through our vacation, Hugh and I contacted a real estate agent named Phyllis, who took us around to look at available properties. On Friday afternoon, we made an offer on an oceanfront cottage not far from the one we were renting. Before sunset, our bid was accepted. I made the announcement at the dinner table and got the reaction I had expected.
我年轻时告诉自己，有一天我会买一栋海滩小屋，然后它就是大家的了，只要他们遵循我严酷的规则，且永远不停止感谢我。于是，在度假到中段的周三早上，休和我联系了一位名叫菲莉丝（Phyllis）的房地产经纪人，她带我们去看了待售房产。周五下午，我们在离出租屋不远的地方对一栋海滨小屋出价。日落前，我们的出价被接受了。我把这个消息在餐桌上宣布，得到了我预想中的反应。
"Now wait a minute," my father said. "You need to think clearly here."
“等等，”父亲说。“你得清醒点思考。”
"I already have," I told him.
“我已经想清楚了，”我告诉他。
"OK, then how old is the roof? How many times has it been replaced in the past 10 years?"
“好的，那么屋顶多老了？过去10年换过几次？”
"When can we move in?" Gretchen asked.
“我们可以什么时候搬进去？”格雷琴问。
Lisa wanted to know if she could bring her dogs, and Amy asked what the house was named.
丽莎想知道她能不能带她的狗，艾米问房子叫什么名字。
"Right now it's called Fantastic Place," I told her, "but we're going to change it." I used to think the ideal name for a beach house was the Ship Shape. Now, though, I had a better idea. "We're going to call it the Sea Section."
“现在叫‘梦幻之地’（Fantastic Place），”我告诉她，“但我们要改名。我以前觉得海滩小屋最理想的名字是‘船形’（Ship Shape）。但现在，我有更好的主意。”“我们要叫它‘海部分’（Sea Section，谐音双关，意为‘性区域’）。”
My father put down his hamburger. "Oh, no, you're not."
父亲放下了汉堡包。“噢，不，你不能。”
"But it's perfect," I argued. "The name's supposed to be beachy, and, if it's a pun, all the better."
“但它太完美了，”我争辩说。“名字得有海滩气息，如果是双关语，那就更好。”
I brought up a cottage we'd seen earlier in the day called Dune Our Thing, and my father winced. "What about naming it Tiffany?" he said.
我提起了那天早些时候看到的叫“沙丘我们的事”（Dune Our Thing，谐音双关，意为‘搞定它’）的小屋，父亲皱了皱眉头。“叫它蒂芙尼怎么样？”他说。
Our silence translated to, let's pretend we didn't hear that.
我们的沉默传达出的意思是，让我们假装没听见那个。
He picked his hamburger back up. "I think it's a great idea-- the perfect way to pay our respects."
他重新拿起汉堡。“我觉得这是个好主意——表达我们敬意的完美方式。”
"If that's the case, we could name it after Mom," I told him, "or half after Mom and half after Tiffany. But it's a house, not a tombstone, and it wouldn't fit in with the names of the other houses."
“如果是那样，我们可以用妈妈的名字来命名，”我告诉他，“或者一半纪念妈妈，一半纪念蒂芙尼。但这是一栋房子，不是墓碑，它不符合其他房子的命名风格。”
"Aw, baloney," my father said. "Fitting in-- that's not who we are. That's not what we're about."
“噢，胡扯，”父亲说。“符合风格——那不是我们是谁。那不是我们关心的重点。”
Paul interrupted to nominate the Conch Sucker.
保罗插话提名“海螺吸盘”（Conch Sucker，谐音骂人词）。
Amy's suggestion had the word "seaman" in it, and Gretchen's was even dirtier.
艾米的建议里有“海员”（seaman，谐音双关）这个词，格雷琴的甚至更脏。
"What's wrong with the name it already has," Lisa asked.
“它原来的名字有什么不好，”丽莎问。
"No, no, no," my father said, forgetting, I think, that this wasn't his decision. A few days later, after the buyer's remorse had kicked in, I'd wonder if I hadn't bought the house as a way of saying, see, it's just that easy-- no hemming and hawing, no asking to look at the septic tank. Rather, you make your family happy and iron out the details later.
“不，不，不，”父亲说，我想他忘了这不是他的决定。几天后，买房后悔期过去后，我甚至怀疑自己买这房子是不是为了说：看，事情就是这么简单——不用犹豫不决，不用去检查化粪池。相反，你让家人开心，细节以后再理顺。
The cottage we bought is two stories tall and was built in 1978. It's on proper stilts and has two rear decks, one above the other, overlooking the ocean. It was rented to vacationers until late September, but Phyllis allowed us to drop by and show it to the family the following morning, after we checked out of the house we'd been staying in.
我们买的小屋两层高，建于1978年。它有正规的桩子，有两个后甲板，一个在另一个上面，俯瞰着海洋。它一直租给度假者到9月底，但菲莉丝允许我们在第二天早上从住的小屋退房后顺便过来给家人看看。
A place always looks different-- worse, most often-- after you've made the commitment to buy it. So while the others raced up and down the stairs, claiming their future bedrooms, I held my nose to a vent and caught a whiff of mildew. The sale included the furniture, so I also made an inventory of the Barcaloungers and massive TVs I would eventually be getting rid of, along with the shell-patterned bedspreads and cushions with anchors on them.
同一个地方总会看起来不一样——而且往往更糟——在你做出购买承诺之后。所以当其他人在楼梯间上下飞奔，抢着未来的卧室时，我把鼻子凑近通风口，闻到了一股霉味。销售包括家具，所以我还盘点了一下我最终要处理掉的巴克罗躺椅（Barcaloungers）和巨型电视机，还有那些带贝壳图案的床罩和印有船锚的靠垫。
"For our beach house, I want to have a train theme," I announced. "Trains on the curtains, trains on the towels-- we're going to go all out."
“我们的海滩屋，我想用火车主题，”我宣布。“窗帘上有火车，毛巾上有火车——我们要全搞成这样。”
"Oh, brother," my father moaned.
“噢，天哪，”父亲呻吟道。
We sketched a plan to return for Thanksgiving. And after saying goodbye to one another, my family splintered into groups and headed off to our respective homes. There had been a breeze at the beach house, but once we left the island the air grew still. As the heat intensified, so did the general feeling of depression.
我们规划了感恩节回来。在互相道别后，家人分裂成小组，前往各自的家。海滩屋那边曾有微风，但离开岛屿后，空气变得静止。随着热度增强，忧郁感也随之加重。
Throughout the '60s and '70s, the road back to Raleigh took us past Smithfield and a billboard on the outskirts of town that read, "Welcome to Klan Country." This time we took a different route, one my brother recommended. Hugh drove, and my father sat beside him. I slumped down in the back seat next to Amy, and every time I raised my head I'd see the same soybean field or low-slung cinder block building we'd seemingly passed 20 minutes earlier.
在整个60和70年代，回罗利的路会经过史密斯菲尔德（Smithfield），镇郊有一个广告牌写着：“欢迎来到三K党领地”。这次我们走了一条弟弟推荐的路。休开车，父亲坐在他旁边。我瘫倒在后座艾米旁边，每次抬头，看到的都是我们20分钟前似乎已经经过的大豆田或矮矮的煤渣块建筑。
We'd been on the road for a little more than an hour when we stopped at a farmer's market. Inside an open air pavilion, a woman offered complimentary plates of hummus served with a corn and black bean salad, so we each accepted one and took seats on a bench. 20 years earlier, the most a place like this might have offered was fried okra. Now there was organic coffee and artisanal goat cheese. Above our heads hung a sign that read "Whispering Dove Ranch." And just as I thought that we might be anywhere, I noticed that the music piped through the speakers was Christian, the new kind, which says that Jesus is awesome.
我们在路上开了不到一个小时就停在了一个农贸市场。在一个露天凉亭里，一位女士提供了免费的鹰嘴豆泥，配玉米和黑豆沙拉，所以我们每个人都拿了一份，在长椅上坐了下来。20年前，这样的地方最多提供炸秋葵。现在有了有机咖啡和手工山羊奶酪。我们头顶挂着一个写着“低语鸽子牧场”的牌子。就在我以为我们可以在任何地方时，我注意到通过扬声器播放的音乐是基督教音乐，那种新的类型，宣扬耶稣非常棒的。
Hugh brought my father a plastic cup of water. "You OK, Lou?"
休给父亲拿了一杯塑料杯水。“你还好吗，卢？”
"Fine," my father answered.
“挺好，”父亲回答。
"Why do you think she did it?" I asked as we stepped back into the sunlight. For that's all any of us were thinking, had been thinking since we got the news. Musn't Tiffany have hoped that whatever pills she'd taken wouldn't be strong enough and that her failed attempt would lead her back into our fold? How could anyone purposefully leave us, us of all people?
“你觉得她为什么这么做？”我们走进阳光里时我问。因为这就是我们所有人都在想的，自从收到消息后一直在想的事。蒂芙尼难道没希望她吃的那些药不够强力，而她失败的尝试能让她回到我们怀抱吗？怎么会有人有目的地离开我们，偏偏是我们？
This is how I thought of it, for though I've often lost faith in myself, I've never lost faith in my family in my certainty that we are fundamentally better than everyone else. It's an archaic belief, one I haven't seriously reconsidered since my late teens, but still I hold it. Ours is the only club I'd ever wanted to be a member of, so I couldn't imagine quitting. Backing off for a year or two was understandable, but to want out so badly that you'd take your own life?
我就是这么想的，因为虽然我经常对自己失去信心，但我从未对家庭失去信心，我坚信我们从根本上比其他人更好。这是一个古老的信念，自从青少年晚期以来我就没认真重新考虑过，但我依然坚持。我们是唯一我曾想加入的俱乐部，所以我无法想象退出。离开一两年还能理解，但想退出到这种地步，以至于你会结束自己的生命？
"I don't know that it had anything to do with us," my father said. But how could it have not? Doesn't the blood of every suicide splash back on our faces?
“我不知道这和我们有什么关系，”父亲说。但怎么可能无关呢？每个自杀者的血不都会溅回到我们脸上吗？
At the far end of the parking lot was a stand selling reptiles. In giant tanks were two pythons, each as big around as a fire hose. The heat seemed to suit them, and I watched as they raised their heads, testing the screened ceilings. Beside the snakes was a low pen corralling an alligator with its mouth banded shut. It wasn't full grown, but perhaps an adolescent, around 3 feet long, and grumpy looking. A girl had stuck her arm through the wire and was stroking the thing's back while it glared, seething. "I'd like to buy everything here just so I could kill it," I said.
停车场尽头有一个卖爬行动物的摊位。巨大的水箱里有两条蟒蛇，每一条都像消防水带那么粗。热度似乎很适合它们，我看着它们抬起头，试探着带纱窗的天花板。蛇旁边是个低矮的围栏，关着一只嘴被绑住的短吻鳄。它还没成年，也许是未成年，大约3英尺长，看起来很暴躁。一个小女孩把胳膊伸进铁丝网里，抚摸着它的背，它怒目而视，火冒三丈。“我想买下这里的一切，只是为了能杀了它们，”我说。
My father mopped his forehead with Kleenex. "I'm with you, brother."
父亲用面巾纸擦了擦额头。“我支持你，兄弟。”
When we were young and would set off for the beach, I'd look out the window at all the landmarks we drove by-- the Purina silo on the south side of Raleigh, the Klan billboard-- knowing that when we passed them a week later I'd be miserable. Our vacation over, now there'd be nothing to live for until Christmas. My life is much fuller than it was back then, yet this return felt no different. "What time is it?" I asked Amy.
小时候，当我们出发去海滩时，我会从窗户看着我们经过的所有地标——罗利南侧的普瑞纳（Purina）粮仓、三K党广告牌——知道当我们一周后经过它们时，我会感到痛苦。假期结束了，现在直到圣诞节之前，活着就没什么意义了。我的生活比那时候充实多了，但这种回程的感觉却没什么两样。“几点了？”我问艾米。
And instead of saying, "Who cares?" she said, "You tell me. You're the one with the watch on."
她没有说“谁在乎？”，而是说，“你自己看吧。戴着表的人是你。”
At the airport a few hours later, I picked sand from my pockets and thought of our final moments at the beach house I'd bought. I was on the front porch with Phyllis, who had just locked the door, and we turned to see the others in the driveway below us. "So is that one of your sisters?" she asked, pointing to Gretchen.
几小时后的机场，我从口袋里捡出沙子，想起了我在买下的海滩屋度过的最后时刻。我和菲莉丝在前廊上，她刚锁上门，我们转头看到楼下的车道上有其他人。“那是你姐妹中的一个吗？”她指着格雷琴问。
"It is," I said. "And so are the two women standing on either side of her."
“是的，”我说。“站在她两边的两位女士也是。”
"Then you've got your brother," she observed. "That makes five. Wow. Now, that's a big family."
“然后还有你弟弟，”她观察道。“那是五个。哇。真是个大家庭。”
I looked at the sunbaked cars we would soon be climbing into, furnaces every one of them, and said, "Yes. It certainly is."
我看着我们即将钻进去的那些被太阳晒透的汽车，每一辆都是火炉，然后说：“是的。确实如此。”
David Sedaris. This story appears in his book, Calypso, and in his forthcoming collection, Best of Me. We want to share the phone number for the National Suicide Prevention Hotline. That number is 1-800-273-8255. Again, 1-800-273-8255.
大卫·塞达里斯。这个故事出现在他的书《卡吕普索》（Calypso）以及他即将出版的文集《最好的我》（Best of Me）中。我们想分享全国预防自杀热线的电话号码。那个号码是1-800-273-8255。再念一遍，1-800-273-8255。
[MUSIC - "DAY AT THE BEACH" BY ATLANTIC THRILLS]
[音乐 - Atlantic Thrills乐队《Day at the Beach》]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同参与。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。
Production help on this rerun from Sarah Abdurrahmana, Noor Gill, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Research help today from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to Willow Yamauchi, Craig Desson, and the Factory Theater in Toronto.
本期重播的制作协助来自萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼娜（Sarah Abdurrahmana）、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）和马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。今天的研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。音乐协助来自达米安·格雷夫（Damian Graef）和罗伯·盖迪斯（Rob Geddis）。特别感谢威洛·山内（Willow Yamauchi）、克雷格·德森（Craig Desson）以及多伦多的工厂剧院。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, or as we like to call him--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia），或者我们喜欢叫他——
The grape smuggler, the Miami meat tent, the dingaling sling, the Saint-Tropez truffle duffle.
那个葡萄偷运者，迈阿密肉块帐篷，晃动吊带，圣特罗佩松露袋。
I'm Ira Glass. Don't forget the sunscreen. I'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。别忘了防晒霜。下周我会带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。